Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello.
Hi,
hi, hi.
Welcome in.
Hello, hello.
Hello.
Good.
Good day.
Good day to you.
Good.
Good day.
Yo, wait, good day.
Hello, wait, good day.
That's awesome, you know.
Wait.
Thank goodness you're making it.
Guys, okay.
Today's stream, it might be a little crazy, all right?
I just got home.
I accidentally sandwiched three things today.
my mom was like hey can you come over saturday and i was like i guess i just got home like 15 minutes ago after that and then i have stream and then in three hours my friend is moving away so i'm going to to a dinner with her and so i have i might be speedrunning a little bit today of
So, I don't want to yop for too long because I do want to beat this game.
I heard it's like two to three hours.
And I have, I'm literally supposed to be there in three hours.
So I apologize if I'm just like, okay, we gotta go here next.
We gotta go here next.
We're speedrunning a little bit.
So sorry.
But we'll get through it.
Oh my goodness.
This is a meat pie.
Fly, Mickey fly.
We're going, we're going.
Tiny Tom's, tiny pie.
Oh.
You simply won't get Tanya.
I won't, oh thank goodness.
Not quite peas, not quite beans, but something special in between.
I picked them out of my food.
Barbara, get the big plants out.
Oh, yeah, I do.
Give your wife the best.
give her big ron's big pies big frauds big pies why do i feel like i'm watching that like back to school backpacks backpacks come and get your backpacks bami bazaar's buttery noobs bami bazaar's buttery noobs bami bazaar's buttery nobs bami bazaar's buttery nobs oh bami bazaar's buttery nobs how do you say that so bad
good right good so that's bansard strange place i know but they need what we're selling his hair is taped onto his head meeting with the lord mayor today so don't miss that bus are you listening oh my god what are you still doing here boy get out okay okay grab a cup of tea oh can i get up oh i'm up hello hello
Carol, I'm going to need another top up of the ladder.
How do I get out?
Yes, it's happened again.
Oh, let's see.
VTuber, get going.
I'm going, I'm going.
I gotta escape.
There's no doors in here.
Two days since last.
Chip-pan fire.
Can I talk to him?
Hello?
Here we go.
Oh, there is a door!
Which is who is up to crying out loud!
Oh.
Am I about to die?
Oh my god!
She shoots!
She scores!
Oh my gosh, I feel so...
I feel so bratish.
A video game!
Hello!
Just like home, really?
Ooh!
Do you see you?
Bondsworth!
Did you guys see the short that Vicky posted?
Why are we there?
Anyway.
I'm sorry, love.
Mr. Mayor's in the meeting.
Because we're meeting the mayor.
Why are we so small?
But if you just sit there, I'll let you know when he's ready.
All right, love.
Oh.
Can I play?
Things to do.
Show me.
I can jumping up and down.
I can sitting down.
I can visit Barnesworth.
I can knock.
Excuse me.
Nice to see a game that's willing to have a protagonist canonically the same size as Mint Real Live.
Hello, Minky.
This game is wild.
I hope you like it.
Thank you.
Pubs.
We can go to the pubs.
Wait, I just left.
Oh.
I left the reception.
I'm visiting Barnsworth.
I'm punching everything.
Oh my gosh, wait!
They said visit Barnsworth, but they did not say that I couldn't vandalize Barnsworth.
let's go i'm literally destroying everything oh oh my gosh why am i like this why do i just slap i'm gonna slap this guy's ass good morning good morning nice to have you around yeah yeah
you like it when i do that yeah yeah you're a freaky little fella
What are you doing?
Thank goodness you're here.
Oh my god, he said the thing!
I spied a shiny tuppence down this hair I run off.
A tuppence.
But more fool me, my arm has become trappence.
Trappence!
Well, what am I, what do you want me to do about that?
No ball games and no parking.
Hello, Minto and Wisps, my advice for today.
Eat some fish and chips and head on down to the pub and grab yourself a pint and watch some Minto.
Yeah!
I'm destroying...
Oh, I'm...
really just destroying everything what about this grandpa is it because the pub is close oh wait this is an end let me in let me in I made him I made he did a little he had a little he did a Willie accident a wee Willie accident I can what's the special give it to me straight doc what is going on I'm destroying a drunk driver hey what's going on in this city I'm literally destroying everything we can't feed the milk snatcher out watch out for that guy there's just cigarette butt's everywhere there's just litter everywhere bootleg still at large wake up
is this really how it is in memory Bobby odd jobs I think I stepped in something nasty I'll turn up the dr. bum bum never forget
Guy, he has a real thick head of hair.
Chest of hair?
Oh no, lost cat!
Also lost one child.
This is all just real.
I did all of this today, it's real.
Oof, oof, oof, oof, oof.
I'm literally slapping everybody.
Oh my gosh, somebody actually...
I won't slap you.
You're doing a good job.
Well, actually, you're doing a job.
It may not be the best...
There's so much to pick up.
You are the people's man.
I'm all up in his booty.
Cheerio, Miss.
I think you dropped these British pounds in the puddle back there.
Well, off you pop.
It'll be raining again soon.
Cheerio, cheerio, cheerio.
Cheerio.
Yeah, the mayor's asked me to clean up this little rose garb.
Okay, you can start by getting on that mower Okay, where's the mower?
There's Oh my gosh, there's two rats Three rats we've reached we've reached levels of rats that no one has reached before Wait, where's oh here it is
I love you Oh, he's talking to me.
I'm blocking the other flower.
Where is...
I love you.
Oh, I'm doing the mowing.
I get how cute.
I love you.
It's like a horror movie.
He's getting closer and closer.
Oh my god.
I love you.
Oh, just mowing that gravel.
Good job, little guy.
Oh my gosh.
I did a good job.
I mowed the grass.
That is a fine statement.
Oh look, they're still here.
Wait, why did I mow the grass?
this part.
Yeah, I did a good job.
Oh, I broke it.
Wait, why is it broken?
What did I do?
Sometimes I just step in, like, gum or something.
It's terrible.
I did it!
Nice firm grip on that mower, lad.
I tell you, Reggie's wife could learn a thing or two.
Reggie's wife taking strays.
Polite notice.
Hello, big lies.
Who's saying silly me?
How do you do, young man?
Hi!
Almost done, and then I can finally get home to my puzzles.
I love puzzles.
No chance of any of them around here, though.
Oh.
Oh, where are you?
Well, I guess no breakfast for me.
I guess not.
It sounds like a you problem.
One rot, two rot, three rot.
Oh my gosh!
This is so lovely!
Rats are rats and we are the rats!
What's this?
Parked vans.
Never caught moving.
Oh, oops.
I wonder who Florence and Colin are.
You need help?
Oh!
Nick's bricks come get your bricks bricks by the brick bricks by the bag high quality bricks by Nick that's me
it's so silly close today a problem with chicken ah but that's like your whole business I would be point phantom ah what's happening I'm sorry mister we're not helping at the moment because this adult has lost my keys uh-oh and now we've got to wait for that useless locksmith oh i'm sorry mrs meg what am i like why is morty from rick and morty in this game oh geez i'm sorry i lost the keys when wang has a body of water called pond
oh it's going down now.
There's so many sound effects everywhere.
Oh my gosh!
Dang I'm getting right in between the legs.
Oh Charlie, I hope he gets that tuppence.
Perhaps you might see about sourcing some lubrication.
The butter!
She is... is that her Oh.
Um...
We gotta...
Maybe there's a tuppence in here.
What is a tuppence?
Is that a currency?
Okay, let's see.
Find the keys.
Maybe I can find them somewhere.
Sorry.
No?
Are you awake?
At the top pence.
Two pence.
Oh.
All that for two pence.
Hmm.
I'm just hopping along.
Don't mind me.
Oh, no.
My wife could let me think I'll do.
She could.
Oh, silly me.
Where am I supposed to find the keys?
If I hit them enough, maybe they come out.
There's so many bugs in this town.
Not the burglar.
Oh,
I can hit everybody.
Find a locksmith.
You're right.
But what's a locksmith look like?
Is this the locksmith?
Oh, wait.
Maybe this place opened too.
Aha!
Oh!
That looks like a locksmith's car!
Now then, Larry.
How about a cobblest pint, eh?
I was so sorry.
It's like a normal pipe.
But I take both my shoes off.
Excuse me.
I love to, Ronnie, but the bee is coming out all flat.
Well, why don't you go down into the center and knock a few bells about?
Slum chance of that.
I don't even know how to get downstairs.
You can't get downstairs in your own blinking public house.
So I gotta go downstairs.
Florence normally does it, but she's off today.
Good morning.
Florence!
We need...
i think i just got flushed well you're down there lad give those bottles a shake up won't you okay you got it sir
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah they're gonna be over there might be an explosion am i doing all this for free what am i working a charity here a long break in work today.
Thank goodness you're here.
Um.
Beep.
Boo-looloo-looloo.
Oh.
Just kidding.
My music wasn't good enough for you.
I'm gonna get I'm gonna get white man wasted.
Oh no.
Every bubble must be popped.
Yes.
what's this oh ah nothing like a nice white pipe to start the day every morning i wake up can of lager and i do a big wee then i get out of bed and go downstairs for my morning bite okay is that healthy steady hands to be a locksmith you do he looks like a pickle throw myself a door a pickle
oh okay ah larry you were just talking about my morning pint yes i think i'll take it now please right you are ronnie another morning pint coming up you're working today then fellow yes no no no in fact i'm sure it's being eggs already i think i'll be back in a moment for my morning my morning oh there he goes there he goes let's pour you a pint in the hall me too i'm the house oh oh what ronnie's a character he'll be back later i reckon I think there's a hair in my soup,
sir.
Not just white man wasted.
British white man wasted.
Oh, no, wait.
I went back, my bad.
Do I have to go through the whole segment again?
We're fine.
He's just gonna pour me another one.
On.
Thank you very much.
Out of my way.
Oh my god, the whole town is here.
It's no use.
Wait, do you think they think it's each other?
He's like...
She's like, you're so feisty today, dear.
Oh, you too.
Little lady.
Okay, let's head over.
Oh!
Sir?
Oh, you're good.
Oh, no, he didn't get his...
Oh.
Put Ronnie in a recovery position.
Is it because he did get his morning pint or...
Didn't?
Excuse me.
I need some butter.
I need some ba- You're welcome.
You're welcome.
Help yourself to our front back though.
Cool.
Oh.
Darling!
What an earth are you doing with that moth boy?
This poor guy's got a black eye!
My mom's got me back on the Mercury again.
Give me strength.
Oh my god!
Poor little guy!
What do we got back here?
but they're mixed.
Oh, you found me.
I'm the Fridgestote.
And I'm awfully frigid.
Ah, no, I just...
I'm actually the town Vole if you catch my meaning.
What?
I...
Not quite sure I understand.
There we go.
Oh, there we keep going.
and here we keep continuing
oh my gosh we made it
I'm glad I censored him eating it on my mark Three, two, one, Eve!
How?
Oh.
Ooh.
Did he get it?
What's this?
Oh, that was very a thruppence.
T'was a thruppence.
Pray tell, young thruppence.
We're best to spend ye.
Hmm?
What hell, what luck?
A wishing well.
It's the thruppence.
Godspeed, young thruppence.
No.
Oh.
What is happening?
Why do I feel like I'm watching like a sketch?
Like a comedy skit.
Uh-oh.
Free Charlie's hand.
Oh, I'm awake.
I'm alive.
I'm fine.
Oh, get me out of here.
Wait, why can't I get out?
There we go.
How queer?
Wait, the subtitles were different though, no?
The way they look at each other!
No, no way.
The subtitles are normal English.
They actually translate it.
Oh, who the heck is this guy?
You all right?
What you carrying in there?
Oh, he's got his bricks!
He's got his bricks!
He's all bricked up, as the kids say.
Quite literally.
What else we got around?
This guy is not looking so good.
He's looking real green.
Are you okay?
That far right.
Okay, who else do we need to fix?
Oh, let's go into that hole.
Oh, what's in the police box?
See it, smell it, sword it.
What happened in 92?
Excuse me, sir!
I would like to report vandalism.
There's some guy going around the town, literally painting the streets yellow.
All the crime.
What could have happened in 92?
I've never seen a hole as big as that.
We neither.
Oh, there we go.
He's slapping everything and everyone!
The queen.
No!
Lady Diana?
Like Princess Diana?
Do
you think it'll work this time, Jasper?
Oh dear.
Oh, there's no use, Marge.
Roger is a nonce.
How have you been cooking fish and chips all this time?
Oh, I just do a cold fry usually.
Hang on a minute.
A cold fry.
Where's the Blinken Spanner?
Stop yelling at me!
It'll be that senile old fishmonger fish down at the market.
You better get down there and find it.
Or it'll be cold chips till the cows come home.
Oh, sorry.
There's just a little man in here instead.
Roger's wife could learn a thing or two.
I didn't walk right for a week last time.
And that vinegar smells only just washed out.
Salt yourself.
What'd they do?
Wait, what's he mean by that?
Oh?
What?
What happened?
Wet.
chips.
Marge's menu.
Fish and chips.
Ten bob.
Fish or chips?
Can of pop.
Ten bob!
The prices are too high!
Kids steal.
Just eat some of your mums.
And the health and safety rating.
They're piss poor.
I think we gotta get out of here.
Wait, where are we?
I don't recognize this.
Where are we?
Oh, two of them, two of them!
Three of them!
Wait, one, two, three.
Driving school.
Both goes on the bridge, hands at half by seven, but never so gently, best foot forward.
That's okay.
I couldn't get it quite right my first 48 times either.
There's nothing like walking this.
Hello, there's a pedestrian here.
There is a pedestrian here.
Oh my gosh, wait.
This is a parking meter.
Give me your cash.
Lester packs lunches.
Lester, that guy can't even pack a punch.
Good day, Minto.
It appears there's a super...
Typhoon!
Here in the next few hours, so I might not be able to tune in the next week through the power outages.
I need to know if there's plans for a Minto figure in the future.
I don't have any plans for a Minto figure in the future.
Sorry.
But stay safe!
Super Typhoon.
Bumbley.
Council says We're going to get these dogs buried By end of the day Dogs That's just what we call a lame pipe Okay Which is what we call a shaggin Shaggin Humpty Dumpty Sight on a wall Humpty Dumpty had a great fall Oh my bad
No parking No loitering No dogging No
Biff spins.
Their biff is everywhere.
What's the dogging?
It could happen to you.
Wait.
I've got a sausage here.
Would you like it?
Here you go.
Ah!
I've dropped it.
Oh!
That's okay.
I've got another.
Oh.
Ah!
I've dropped it again.
It's alright.
I've got some more inside.
Buckinghamoo.
Is it like raw dogging?
I'm waiting for Bobby Bash to come back.
Looking for a good time!
From 1 a.m., 3 p.m., half to noon.
Oh my gosh, I didn't know this game involved platforming.
Oh my gosh, we're going to the moon.
Oh!
Oh, hello!
What have we got here then?
A towel in the owl.
I'm going to move myself over a little bit.
I'll put me down the apples and pay you the jiffy.
Ow!
Still at large.
Ah!
That's a whole lot of soot.
Ah, a fine mess.
Don't bother there, young man.
Help yourself to some scramble bread.
Oh, so, oh my gosh, I'm so sorry.
Hold on, I just wanted to make myself smaller, a little bit.
Okay, that should be good, I think.
Thank you, sir.
You have a nice, sturdy house here.
I'm just checking it out.
Making sure that nothing...
Ten bob!
I'm making sure that nothing is...
Um...
Everything is...
In tip-top...
Tip-top shape.
Um, is there anything you want me to do?
Oh, I can leave.
Oh, thank goodness you're here.
I've been sucking this pipe all morning.
I haven't got a drop out of this.
Oh, hi again.
Gentlemanther here is any crusted over.
We need to dampen that topsoil pronto.
Pronto.
Oh.
Keep sucking.
Wanted for crime.
It's not me, though.
That doesn't look anything like me.
Inspector Minky here.
Just making sure things are up to code.
Slap, slap, slap.
I'm slapping, I'm slapping.
Come on, get in, Durban-time.
Now, all day.
Here, I'll help you out.
Get in there, kid.
Get in there.
God, the booty cheeks on that guy.
Hmm.
Is there something that is causing...
Oh!
That is causing the water to be stuck.
Is it on?
He's all cheeks.
I'm just making sure everything's in order.
Ooh, strawberries.
Hello.
You know, I love cucumbers, but I cannot stand a snake.
Every time I put one in my mouth, I'm nearly sick.
When you do me a favor, if you see any snails, give them a click around the ear hole for me.
Oh.
Why are you eating the sna- you don't wash your food first?
Sister- oh, no snail zone.
Sue hurts snails.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, I just smushed that guy.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize I was killing this.
I'm destroying this garden.
Wait, but we have to find some snails, maybe.
I'm gonna look for one.
Is that a rocket ship on the tree?
Okay, I'm looking for a snail.
I'm looking for a snail.
I see none.
I think this place is...
This place is clear.
I'm jumping in.
I'm going in.
I went in!
No, I'll dee!
What could be the problem here?
Hello!
I'm a w-
It was supposed to be a friendly handshake.
It was supposed to be a handshake!
I promise!
Tunneling for the desperate gardener.
Doesn't
know hands i don't know whoa liminal spaces may be less engaging than they appear okay what's going on out here who's looking at me
are we siphoning water from this shop are we just taking water from the from the
What does that say?
I think I fixed it.
Good day!
Oh yeah!
Oh wait, I keep saying good day, but that's not...
Hello!
What's happening in here?
Oh, there's a man in here!
Ah!
Sorry.
I have no idea how that got there.
I pull the other one, passing off my spanner as a stiff kipper, is it?
But we've been friends for 40 years.
Why on earth?
The fish, all the fish have cigarettes, why?
Why didn't you scare me the excuses, you fat trout?
I'm taking this back to my toolbox where it belongs.
Every single fish has a cigarette, why?
Except this guy is...
Fish and Sigs.
Oh, you're right, you're right.
Oh, Bish for fish.
Bish for Sigs.
What's he doing?
That one.
No pies.
Oh, wow.
Hold on.
What's the fish pop?
What's up this about then?
What are you going to do?
What for nobody?
I have a tea.
What fish popped.
Why don't you let's go, Beverly, to make you one?
Empty box.
Just a box.
Hello.
The Crankmaster 2000.
I'll take five.
Doug's rugs.
Is there cigarettes in these two?
Hello.
No more digests.
Can't believe that big one.
No pie.
Stop playing with them.
with your food.
Doug's the name.
Hi Doug!
Where's the rugs at?
I see none.
Oh, here they are.
I'll take...
Your finest...
I'll take this one.
Your finest rug.
It's just garbage everywhere.
Is this the real?
Is this the real truth?
We've gone too far!
What's happening?
Sorry, I missed your super chat.
I'm sorry.
Oh!
can I help these are pigs oh my god oh wait I think I'm about to oh what's
going on oh whoa whoa whoa oh hello hi there's
so many little details everywhere yeah very handsome my dog your dog such a good boy oh my god
what about the rest of him he looks quite happy though i think it's okay switzerland one way
it's a hot dog you got there I heart Barnesworth can I get three but what's that what's there what's that place socks pretty stiff I definitely thought I said pre sniffed bargain bin I'll take your finest lace stiff
as worse is worse what's that I'm a little guy who doesn't care about anything except destroying I've I'm little you could call me little Godzilla I'm just here to destroy this town what a mess yeah what's going on I can't run through that can I no
how do they get stiff from not being washed
can I not go back to the town I feel like I missed so much I went up the I went up the through the roof and
I'll take your shait shait
quality flowed.
Does it go away?
No veggies for me today.
There's definitely rats in here.
Find all the singing mice!
Hello.
Five across.
Rope of wire.
Rope?
Oh, no.
That's four across.
Ah.
A horseshoe.
Well, good thing he didn't ask for help.
you know oh gosh she's still trying to drive whoa what's a porky knob oh my big bum close due to smacking bum bum how often does this happen to you sir
he's back open his back oh
I think if I get away far enough he'll open back up the menace is on the loose the little little Godzilla is on the loose you're nearly at big Rhons big pies tiny pies all I need is my burger so true everything is 10 bob oily bops get them fresh get them warm get them moist yep I'll take one I'll take one give me one oily bop please No breakfast and now no lunch.
We'll do something about it.
I don't know.
Oh, the pies.
Whoa.
Oh, my goodness you're here.
Yeah?
You better get yourself into here now.
One second.
I want to eat mercury.
Or have a fun ball.
Please?
What the?
Oh.
I want to eat Mercury!
Guys, don't eat Mercury.
It's not good for you.
I'm dead.
It's fine.
Wait, Yu-Gi-Oh!
No way!
This place has Yu-Gi-Oh!
Yu-Gi-Oh!
It ain't like that.
Pokemans.
Beesh is a trout.
No, that's a fish.
You're talking about bish.
The absolute state of this.
It's so true.
What's he doing in there?
Kind of, like, lead tastes kind of sweet in case you were wondering.
I want a pie.
I'm desperate.
I'm right on with me.
Okay, let's go make some pies.
Oh, you've come just in the nick of time.
I'm here.
I came in as usual.
Opened up shop.
counted till went to make my first pie of the day and then i realized yeah with no meat oh my god i can't make a pie without meat okay it's the second most important ingredient oh i hate to say but you have to get down to sam's hands and pick us up some of his steak i got you oh a sunny steak indeed florence oh get that oven warmed up for when this young man comes man I've got you!
Yes, of course, Mr. Warren.
Rush away!
Let's be having you.
Okay.
We got the meat.
Oh.
Not this guy, though, right?
Oh, okay.
I think now we can go through the place where the car was.
Arby's?
Arby's.
They've got meat.
Oh.
Where are we going?
Oh, where are you going?
Oh, there we are.
Oh, we're here!
How did it work out?
Why is it in your pants?
Cracky, look at the size of this lad's marrow.
There's here the tomatoes are a fruit.
Why is it in your pants though?
Curious.
Wait, how do I...
Here?
I didn't see any snails, ma'am.
I simply do not like snails at all.
But I didn't see any, did you?
Am I crazy?
The faucet.
Oh!
I didn't realize it wasn't on.
gosh wait looks like we didn't need that hose after all lad all right so all we need now is fertilizer yep
do I smell quail who I see it was but a tomato who is saying this oh hello dirty love Herbert dirty love oh where are how am i what is going on hey biz there's some really good looking fish in here yeah hello one's got a nice set of teeth teeth so i hope we catch some of this i'm starving thank you so much for the pig ah the dingle room the most invasive and hostile flower even slightly agitated it will burst and scatter the seed unfortunately i've caught this one It's hard to do any damage.
It looks like...
I could do that.
I could.
I could destroy an entire ecosystem.
And I'll do it.
What happened to Florence?
Oops, sorry.
Where are we now?
Oh my gosh.
I feel like I need a map.
them for you never give an owl a toll
oops oops i can't seem to understand it i pick up all the litter and i put it so true and then next thing i know is roaming everywhere i'll never make a puzzle night at this rate still i do love litter no don't love litter get rid of the litter how they found your sock in there huh wait what's What's going on there?
What's going on with the cow?
A horse?
Hmm...
Cow.
Where are we now?
Men underfoot.
Oh, hello!
Both my dads were diggers.
So there were always spades knocking about the house.
Yeah?
What'd they do in that for?
I'm boiling the kettle.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm also a man underfoot.
Hello?
Oh!
You forgot to lock your door!
Oh my gosh, this guy is taking up the entire front window!
What are you doing that for?
Are you stuck?
Mind that child.
I'll take the Sacrifice.
I'll get electrocuted for you.
Alright, let's go inside that person's house.
Oh.
I can't do anything.
I'm useless.
Oh!
I went through their house.
And we're going through this person's other house.
Oh, and through there.
I'm playing Scooby-Doo.
What's going on?
Oh, hello there, young man.
Hi!
Yep.
My drain pipes are all blocked up over there and I need them cleaning out.
Won't you give it a go?
Okay.
Oh.
Hmm.
Um.
I love you.
Will you marry me?
Who's asking?
Great job!
Oh, we're back in the pipes.
What's wrong with it?
It's only Nancy's new bloody boyfriend.
She's got a new one every week.
All right.
It'll be nice to have a proper sit-down, T.
I'd rather have a sit-down week.
Or be it.
I love eavesdropping.
Anyone here?
Oh my god.
How crude.
Where are we?
Wait.
Oh, we're back in the main area.
Hello.
Bring back asbestos.
I agree.
It's fine.
I am.
Will you marry, Pipito?
Stop it.
Bring back asbestos.
I agree, I agree.
you are being lied to bring it back bring it back let me join your cause
let's see anything else new around here since i've last left it's you you guys don't understand it save the run oh my gosh they've made a mess of this guy what are you eating hey oh it's happened again me pasty pop that might be my that might be my favorite bit so far
oh I I didn't realize I could go in here
oh I do love my mole wife you and your wife should come around sometime we live underground in soil and that anyway I best be off I've got some worms to suck up into my big mole mouth Ooh, can I join?
I love my mole wife.
As opposed to?
What if we had a worm wife?
How controversial?
Could he, it's like Zootopia where they're like, I'm a, I'm a, I'm a, I eat, I eat animals and they're like, no, I'm an herbivore animal.
And it's just like, can the, can the mole who eats worms fall asleep?
in love with the mold.
Do you still love us if we were worms?
Do we kick?
Maybe.
Let's kick then.
Just kick then?
Let's kick?
We'll kick?
I think he's suspicious of me.
I'm kicking better.
I'm doing a much better job.
Would you join me in filling our bellies with diet, Soda.
Scrabs, I can't drink soda.
So sorry, I can't join you in that endeavor.
Oh, they've locked me out.
I guess I'm not meeting the mayor.
I need not butter.
I need meat.
Where was the meat at?
I don't know, love.
We have got bricks at home.
Oh, good make, though.
Still like your bricks?
Oh!
Game is more linear than you think.
I believe that.
I just don't remember where it was.
Oh, wait!
Uh...
I just don't remember.
Did I have to go through the hole?
Through here?
The sewer hole.
Okay, so I was right.
oh what's going on in here hey hello he shows the bits you found his spanner oh okay oh oh my god why are you cracking what reclaiming the spanner for that unfortunately i've just noticed my screwdriver's gone oh thank you for the redirect it's probably that daft glassy carry down at price shaggers right away you go laddy i kind of get into this thing without my trusty screwdriver.
Okay.
Darko, thank you so much for the gifted.
Ducky, thank you so much for the gifted.
Mothman, thank you so much for the gifted.
That fry is still broke.
Come on, I'll eat him raw.
Oh my god.
Damn.
My guy's hungry.
Toast.
Kiss the cook.
I get lonely sometimes.
Are you okay?
I do like to have a little look through the window.
Oh, okay.
What window?
Where are we looking through, huh?
Huh?
I'm just kind of exploring and seeing what...
Oh, it's Kesa!
I don't know.
Mucky pup.
There you go.
I fixed it.
The farm.
Oh, wait, we gotta get the screwdriver here, no?
Hello, hello?
Oh, my gosh, this is where the- Oh, thank goodness you are here.
Yep.
They're everywhere.
Somebody must have laid them down from the roof.
Oops.
Can you fetch a jackbox of rat poison from top shelf?
Oh, you're asking the tiniest person here, huh?
Oh, my gosh, look at them go.
I've been on my best behavior.
I deserve a treat, not a mouse.
The rats everywhere.
Oh, here we go.
Take your rat poison.
No, I don't want to hurt them, though.
Oh, is that the asbestos?
Or...
You're welcome.
Do you have...
A screwdriver here?
Maybe the other direction.
They've gone crazy.
It's because they've gotten sick with power.
Because I enjoyed their...
I enjoyed their...
musical numbers too much.
Employees must wash their teeth.
I hope so.
Hello?
Wait.
Up to the roof.
Oh, can I go up to the roof?
Did I watch cats?
Don't ask me that.
Where are we?
Oh.
Yeah,
they're so cute.
Do your part.
Leave no bin bag unchewed.
Borrowed from biggies.
Remember biggies are not people.
What biggies ever do to them?
What's in here?
Yeah?
Let me in.
I listen to your people.
the song of your people.
I'm too small, guys.
He's got his ration book.
Beware the basher.
Stop the stigma.
Shit everywhere.
Is there something I'm supposed to do here?
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, yeah.
Fancy doing business with you.
I don't discriminate.
I hit everybody.
We are no longer accepting weird avian nodes.
What does that mean?
Hello!
Oh.
What's he pointing at?
Can I get the screwdriver?
How do I take it?
Collins keys!
Oh, there it is.
Okay, cool.
Carrie Louise, pickle.
Passing off my flathead is your produce, is it?
Jasper, why in earth would I do that?
I can't turn my back for a minute in this town without one of you's pinching my tools.
I swear down, I've never seen this before in my life.
The axes are not the axes, but the voices are so funny.
The head office, that's for sure.
I've never seen it before in my life.
You're welcome.
Did I complete it?
Don't put your bin in my bin.
I'll help.
I will help.
I'm in the bath.
Oh, knock it on my door, is it?
It should be fixed now, right?
Hello!
Okay, he's doing it.
Thanks for helping me get the screwdriver back, laddy.
You're so welcome!
I wish I could say we were done, lad.
I really do.
But as I got back, I noticed my hammer's gone walkies.
It must have been pinched by that no-good job, Frank.
He's probably doing it the brook.
Poaching fish as we speak.
Okay.
Where?
Frank?
Why is everybody stealing from you?
Let's see.
Where do I go from here?
Oh, me and you're Ben.
Wait, that's so silly.
Oh, hello.
Quick in Ed, black in lung.
Smoking's best when you start it, young.
I used to go to dishes, but my doctor says that Brian will give me gout.
Not gout.
Okay.
So we're going to Frank's.
I think it was.
This is where I...
Okay, okay.
Oh, I had to go up here.
Oh, okay.
So I actually did the right thing.
I thought...
Okay.
Oh.
I thought I like went all out of order.
Excuse me.
Here he is again.
Ready for another bit of fiddle sticks, are you?
Yes, ma'am.
Awesome, awesome.
Oh, no.
Ah, hello again.
Didn't expect to see you twice in one day.
Sorry, I'm very busy with my inspections.
I'm very, very...
He looks so mad.
I'm sorry!
Gone to rogues.
Hey, what are you guys doing?
I'm a chartered surveyor, and I'm in trouble.
Hold him still, turpentine.
My father's the counter.
Oops.
I didn't mean...
Wait!
I didn't mean to bully him!
I'm trying to punish the kid!
Oh, hey.
I think I killed him, you guys.
She won't even acknowledge me.
What's going on here?
What's actually happening here?
Going here.
I love corn.
I eat all of it.
Hmm.
No snail zone.
Are there any snails?
None.
Corn here.
They say pills here usually.
And I say, gosh, hate that.
But corn here, that's a movement I can get behind.
I gotta go to Frankie's.
Is that what it was?
You think that little worm is okay?
Rogues.
Whoa.
I'm a worm!
He's fine!
Okay.
It's either down the compost heap or off crawling through keyholes at night to find a shiny penny.
How's that for dirty work?
High five!
He's alive and he's well!
Who is up in there?
Freaky.
Okay.
so there's probably a hammer in here just the man i need yeah come in and eat setting up you'll give us an hand again won't you lad what do you say wait you one more there it is there it is everybody get smokes you get smokes you get smokes you get smokes the crabs five in each claw
okay apparently he's going to sands for his run never they are luscious though well are they are luscious no discremen there but another man's meat in your pie what are we Sheffield not at the last time he should hang his head oh yeah Sam's hands.
Do I go in here?
Well, well.
I never thought I'd see the day where the big man will come to me for his meat.
Why are you slapping it like that?
Here, I'll slap it too.
Oh.
What just happened?
Ew.
What's going on?
I don't think I like this one.
Ew.
Oh!
Peter Griffin.
I got you.
I don't think I like this bit.
One dark winter's night, my father brought me and my sisters a lamb each and but a single sheep knife between us.
Mine.
They run through the litter, jolted as I made the cut.
It bleated and bled for a fortnight, and I wept.
Did he just say fortnight?
Oh.
When I was scarcely three years old, me father, mistaking me for a small cut of medicine, blew me out in smokehouse.
It was nearly a day dangling all the embers before my sisters found me.
By then, I was already stricken with a black lung.
The doctor said I shan't likely see my father.
It means 14 days.
No.
I wept.
Oh.
Dugtrio.
Dug.
Dugtro.
I don't like this one, I think.
Oh, my God.
What are we playing?
I'm not quite sure anymore.
Do you know how glue is made?
I knew.
I found out when I was only seven years old.
After me, one went lame.
Mother took a titnaca.
Oh, lame.
And I wept.
Um, yeah, when, when horse girls don't, don't produce results.
Find all of Sam's meat bits.
Oh, excellent word, lad.
A fine cut indeed.
I don't think I have words.
I don't think I Now I suppose all we need to do is What?
I've forgotten The most important ingredient What?
Pie mix Oh Here we are I'm sure there's the number in here somewhere Ah Here it is Pastry Peets Premium Mixture Company Pie Mixer Delivery for Pies Dot Biz Dot Biz Pastry Peets Premium Mixture Company Pie Mixer Delivery for Pies Dot Biz Horrible Raw All right,
lad.
The number is...
One, two, another two, six.
Hello.
Colin, is that you?
Oh, hello, Mr. Ron.
Yeah, past the piece of today.
This took on to my...
Zero one, two, two, six.
Remember that, everybody?
So you've forgotten my pie mix then.
Uh-oh.
I'm ever since sorry, Mr. Ron.
My memory's not been so good since my man...
The business!
He made me boss's post-haste!
Yes, I'll be right over.
Oh, he's running.
I hear him.
Oh, my God!
Oh, there you are, Colin.
Here you go, Mr. Ron.
I came as fast as I could.
Ooh, blaring.
What the chore?
Ooh, hello, Colin.
I had no idea you were in the pie industry.
I see.
Oh, you're always...
wants to work with cross oh young love you're sweaty today colin thanks it's actually butter sleepy super sleepy you should see me get down again i'm like a woman they do look like they're related really oh the doctor says we've got a very similar bone structure it shows you my dentist
Maybe we should have...
I don't know.
Go to the hygiene.
Together sometimes.
Am I doing it?
Am I baking?
Oh, yes.
I'm back.
You made me show on?
Yes, Flores.
I'm
doing it.
I'm cooking?
It doesn't matter now, Flores.
What?
Oh.
Enough for everyone.
What just happened?
I think I cooked the pot.
Ah!
Mmm.
What's happening?
Let me out.
Get your Zendown to big roads where we've made our biggest pie yet.
Ah, Guinness World Record!
How big is the pie?
Oh my god, like so big.
Yeah, that's what I said!
It's a pie so big!
Uh oh.
Drama!
I am close to it since I was a small boy.
A pie so big that I've eaten.
Now, look, I know you've told me before, but why can't you just, well, you know, make your pies a bit...
Bigger?
Bigger.
I think he's gonna murder him.
I think he's gonna kill this guy.
And I wept.
What else?
Oh gosh, what do we have now?
Oh, hello.
I've been tipped off that someone's selling counterfeit goods.
Counterfeit!
It's all for sale.
It could...
Karen would have wanted.
It couldn't be...
The Yu-Gi- Oh my gosh, wait, all the cards are almost gone.
We gotta get our pack, you guys.
We gotta get our Yu-Gi-Gi-Oh cards.
What's in here?
Curious.
Wait, how do I get up here?
Am I too small?
Oh, not yet.
Okay.
I'm too short.
What else we got around here?
Grandma's still with her.
Uh, you okay?
Who's gonna have a right job on getting fertilizer with Roger this state?
Oh, that's right!
The fertilizer!
What's going on in there?
He kicked me out earlier.
I don't think he likes me.
It's trench warfare!
Oh my god!
Don't ask yourself.
You make it a mess of the place.
Get out!
What the devil's gone into your mouth?
I never even mentioned your massive head.
What?
It isn't massive.
Where am I?
Oh.
Roger, there's no shame in it.
Where am I?
I'm in the tomatoes.
Let's get the hell out of here.
When he was a weird lad.
Ow!
The noggin!
I'm sorry, Mr. Peelings.
We did everything we could.
Oh!
Roger's got a big head and he's in my head.
Who you calling Pinhead?
Oh my gosh.
They're so mean to him.
Oh no.
Oh.
He's too big.
Sorry mister.
It's company policy.
Never mind them.
Never mind them, love.
I lied to you.
Oh, get yourself a girl who accepts your big head.
Oh, no!
It's just too big.
Ooh.
Oh, Mike, it's just too big.
Too big.
That whole fate?
No.
Extra and extra, lad.
Too big.
He's heard it his whole life!
Right then, Rog.
I'll see you next week.
My man has trauma!
Well, Roger.
Good luck with that, then.
I'm just gonna shimmy on out of here.
Here we go.
I'm taking a leap.
I'm glad that's over.
I can't stand the fuss.
What?
Can't stand the fuss.
Um...
Can we go through here?
Yes, we can.
Does this go?
Oh, what's going on here?
Oh no, we can't go back that way!
Okay.
This is a family where Estrada always gets me.
It's so funny.
Oh, what do you got there?
Oh, meweeny sausage meal.
Blooming hack.
It's the meat in the bun of the burger that I enjoy.
Wait, what's this?
Any sign of knockoffs?
No, sir.
Blooming hack.
What's this?
Oh, I've never liked to look a clock in the face.
These watches are painted on.
How would you buy it?
Shame for really.
Um, hello, Crimester.
No!
It's him.
Ah!
Bring me beans in.
Hear my breath.
Bring me beans or bring me death.
Okay, well, he fixed our problem.
We can hop up now.
Nice.
Where are we going anyway?
We're platforming?
Let's get him...
Oh.
Hello, sir.
Excuse me, young man.
Get off my soul's glow.
Sorry.
My old-fashioned nightcap.
You didn't want those, did you?
Yeah.
There's a little man on my windowsill.
But can you not see me?
Am I too small?
Sir?
Sir, there's a little man on my windowsill.
You're ready to send, sir.
Sir?
Wait, there's a sensor needed in this game?
It's fine.
I'm scared.
No, unless you're four.
Chat's being paranoid.
There's a tiny bit of dong.
It's a cartoon!
It's okay probably.
Right?
big head yeah yeah well thanks for uh the warning i'm gonna walk slowly because i'm scared it's like going to an art museum you guys and you see you see a pp there too it happens at the art museum oh wow my head really does censor him just perfectly huh
Okay, there's something to that.
Okay, I won't look it down.
Wait.
Convenient sensor right there.
I just won't move.
Okay, sorry.
If I have to see it, you do too.
I'm Wiggity Beanton.
Hey, my plea.
I summon my six girls back to me.
That didn't work.
Go find them.
What am I finding?
Your pants?
Or...
Yeah!
What is he, what is, what is...
Where, why are we like in a cloud?
Sue, Ann, Barb, Lou, Sharon, Liz, what are those?
Those kiss marks?
Wait, oh they're seagulls.
Oh!
There he goes.
Is there another one up here?
Oh wait, my bad.
Don't...
Hello?
It's my bedtime!
Alright, let's go find some seagulls!
Oh.
Dear, oh dear young lad, looks like we just missed him by a train.
I saw him though.
I saw him.
I caught that guy red-handed.
Oh, seagull, seagull!
I'm trying to get the seagull, don't mind me.
There we go.
Oh, nope, those are pigeons.
None of them, none of them.
Let's see.
How long before that pie spoils, you think?
Seagulls, oh seagulls!
How many are there?
Oh, here's another one.
A few days?
Never.
Six.
Oh!
That's so awkward.
Sorry.
what was that five i think
six about six perhaps
seven i like when things become so cringe that people it's not funny but people like just still do it because it's like stupid That's how I feel 6-7 is becoming.
What did I miss?
It's for the bit.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, it's not actually funny.
It's just silly to say it.
Like the Tumblr-e.
We all could use a little more whimsy in our lives and after lives, you know?
So, you don't have to think it's funny, but...
It's just silly.
You know, let people be their silly...
Oh, there it is.
Silly, silly selves.
I'm gonna eat this guy, though.
Sam Hearts Rumps.
Yeah, he does.
Oh, not again.
No, not again.
It's so worth it.
The people will never eat there again.
He'll never open back up because I...
am the rump smacker and I won't stop you can't make me excuse me I have a I have a little weener to go gander at I am a rump smacker hopefully he's put on his pants for company nope absolutely he did not work cabin boy you retrieved my finest lieutenants there's a bright future ahead of you on this ship attention hey
did everybody salute what's in there why is it shaking what's shaking bacon oh we're back here wait it's so lively like it you was so dark before
hang on a minute these coasters are one way wait what oh my gosh an actual vtuber very strange oh he's back
what a silly visual gag it's so funny uh wait mister stopping crying back in nine no we need you now oh my gosh he was right there.
I don't remember.
What did I do next?
What did I need to do?
Um.
I wish there was like a...
Oh, the fertilizer!
Oh, that's right, that's right.
I like the music.
Weeweeweeweewee.
Wait, check the bricks.
And the river.
What was the river?
I remember the guy with the little weed at the river.
Shadow detective, thank you so much for that super job.
Thank you.
Nobody is getting bricks anymore?
Oh, wait.
Big secondhand furniture never used.
Chairs, lamps, doors, and mores.
I got the achievement help Nick open up a new store.
Hello.
Oh my god.
Okay, let's try going back to the garden then.
It was fine in the 70s, and it's fine now.
You are all soft.
I'm just a big old softy.
They're here.
We're back in the pipes.
I can't get enough of these...
Dang pipes.
Oh my gosh.
Is the plate getting further and further to the right?
No.
I'm going to break her.
Hurry down along to the brook before Frank does himself a mischief with my hammer.
Okay.
No.
I don't want to break it.
Oh, look at this now.
My brother's in the bin.
What a stupid bit.
I love it.
I like how every time I come by in these places, something has changed just a little bit.
Oh my gosh, your toast is burnt.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah.
Just letting you know.
Greatest love story ever told.
They're cute.
Hello.
Wait.
Franks.
Is that the guy who...
Hi.
Oh, hi.
I've got some more sausages, and I'm going to poke them through the hole.
Okay, I'm ready to catch.
Oh.
That's all right.
This one?
Oh.
One more?
Yeah, I've dropped that one too.
I'm afraid I've run out of sausages now.
I'll go to the shop and buy some more.
It's...
He's so mysterious.
It's so elusive, it's attractive, you know?
Hello, I'm back.
Okay, okay, Gaffna.
Keep your rhubarb folded on the way down.
My way?
Oh no, no, no, no.
Yo!
You, you little, little dusty gentleman, you.
I'm so sorry!
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
What's going on?
Why are you...
Steady as you go.
What's going on?
The picture?
What about it?
Oh, hello.
I
thought that was their kids GMOs My beautiful baby boy And bigger than I thought
Cream of the crop Grow a lovely tomato Guys um I fear Oh Bobby you old chews stick me soft what can I do you I was gonna say I have to go to the little ghosty's room but there's been reports of crime crime shit that's right have you seen this criminal at all hang on a minute that's no criminal who's that's the honest businessman who sold me this brand new watering can I'm afraid that's no businessman that's bootleg bill oh that's no watering can that's a watering can't no bugger me I paid ten Bob Sterling for that it happens to the best of us,
Herbert.
Just last week he swingled my wife with a wet dream cat, Chef.
So keep your eyes peeled.
Your head on a swivel.
A what?
On your button.
Now I'll need to take this to get down to the station.
Good grief.
This town is going to the night.
You better keep an eye out, lad.
Can you get me out of here?
Nice.
Okay, now I'm going to the little ghosty's room.
Right quick.
I'll be back in a Chiffy, you won't even realize I'm...
Gone.
Okay, let's keep going.
It was just a dramatic pause.
Okay.
Let's keep going.
But not before.
Oh, I wanted to break those.
Hmm.
Corn on the cob.
Corn off the cob.
Yay!
Can I go in?
Wait, is this?
I don't want to go in there, actually.
I lied.
Any snails?
None.
No snails?
No snails.
Oh.
No gardening for you either.
The music is so cute, though.
Oh, I didn't even step on him!
Oh, the fire department.
Tell them, old Charlie's got himself stuck in the well again.
They'll know what it means.
Shut up and have his spoon.
Thank goodness Minciers!
Strike Warlock!
Thank you so much for the peek!
Oh, I think he wants to be kissed by that lady.
Oh, my gosh.
Mr. Man.
Wanted for crime.
What was out here again?
Are you here to give the hand with fishing?
Yeah?
That's bait box over there.
Okay.
I'm coming.
Where's the bait?
Do not bash.
Okay.
We're fine.
Bait box.
Where?
Oh!
Okay.
Ah, good idea.
You can go in and all.
Okay.
Oh.
I'm going down!
I'm getting for the... I'm aiming for... I'm aiming big.
The hammer.
How do I grab it?
Take it.
Take it home.
Oh...
Wait, it's mine!
It's mine!
Oh, I got him!
We're hitting the bridge!
Oh, catch of the day!
You've been up to some mischief with us.
I'll bet what you're all about Jasper.
I don't know I don't know.
I'm taking this back to my toolbox and I'll see you at the triple lad Jasper your puppy doing me nothing
This bait I was like where are we?
Okay
What's this and he said two pound fifty for parking and I said I said, good God, I'm a duck.
I found all the woodland creatures.
Good God, I'm a duck.
Okay, where are we at now?
Oh, we still gotta get to that cow.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, he's still smiling.
He's fine.
He's like, come here, big, big boy.
Wait a second.
second aren't these the the weeds oh wait a second oh oh wait oh no oh no wait am i helping spread them yeah that's the invasive weed though come here big boy i'm all over town uh-oh whoa go against graham's advice oops wait a second um
I think they're in love with you.
Leave me alone.
Oops.
Oh, I messed up, I think.
They're playing...
They're playing Uno.
Bioterrorism?
Um, in here.
You got your hammer?
Everything should be fixed now?
Hi, hello.
Hello.
Sounds like you've missed.
finished I can't even believe the cheek of that wee boy I dread to think the trouble he was up to with this old thing anyway I think I've almost cracked it open take a look inside won't you see if you can't flush all this muck out okay oh wait one second someone said there was a fire the barbecue oh my god um no
her okay not our problem either uno or strip poker the greatest love story of our time hello oh
all right that's your pipes all cleaned out and I fixed the fryer oh thanks lovey I hope it wasn't too much bother I'll put you some chippy on i need water at all but where does all that oil drain out to anyway oh i've got no clue love
the baby oh cannibalism cannibalism cannibalism morning morning
Not us, too.
We fixed the friar.
We did good.
Maybe.
The town is in shambles.
Oh.
What do I have to do now?
What was there to do now?
What's your...
What are you doing?
Okay.
The bin is gone.
What bin?
Oh yeah, the people!
Where'd they go?
Uh oh.
Keep circling around the town.
Yeah, I can't go through there.
Oh my gosh, what's happening?
Oh dear.
Oh, that's in the right state.
Oh!
What happened?
Oh hello there.
young man thank goodness you're here yes i've got this delicious cup of tea here you see yes i'm afraid it's as black as a bin bag in there uh-huh it really is i'd go and get some more milk i would the trouble is i'm afraid i'm i'm you i'm milk shy oh oh okay i got you i got you don't worry i'll go get your milk i'll go get your milk just a little milk shy we all This happens to all of us.
We need some very normal milk.
Yes, yes, yes.
For the children's.
For the children's sake.
Yes?
Oh, thank goodness you hear, lad.
Oh, Bessie's sick as it is.
Oh, Bessie!
She's usually perk her up, though.
Oh, you couldn't go up to Marges and get us some, could you?
What's...
We'll get you some, what?
Who's Marge?
Okay.
Chippies.
Oh, thank you guys.
Chippy, tippy, tippies.
Wow, what a place to live in.
Always something happening.
Chippo.
I will get...
I believe this queue.
I've been here for 40 minutes.
Oh, man.
Marge.
Come on, hurry up.
I'm eating for 10 minutes.
Oh wait, how do I...
A doobie.
Smacking everybody.
Uh...
How?
Oh wait, I have to go...
Oh, I have to go through the back, don't I?
Okay, uh, sheesh.
How do I get there though?
I don't remember.
Um...
Oh, what's wrong?
Oh, you're doing it!
You're doing it!
Good job!
Oh, what's in here?
We're playing Scooby-Doo again.
Yeah, dooby.
Oh, that's right!
Hello.
More we...
A proud tiny pie family.
Uh-oh, but the big pies are taking over.
Oh, they're meeting the family.
How do?
Hi there, Mr. and Mrs. Bingy.
Very nice to meet you both.
Now then, Jack, how about a lager be here?
Ah, go on then.
Hey, I like him already.
Hey.
Dad approved.
Wow, Mrs. Bingy.
This is delicious.
I've never had pie and sweets before.
Thank you, Jackalus.
Jackalus.
Well, what do you know me over your pie at home, lad?
well usually the pie is big enough on its own big enough oh look please don't make a fuss big enough no love i won't have it not under my roof not on my dinner table love please i really didn't mean anything by it wait i'm stuck oh damn and you can shut it your daughter of mine is going with a big pie man oh no one what's going on in here oh I can go inside hello what's going on in here oh it's the person that was sick wake up good morning cousin Susan good morning good morning Yeah,
it's my breakfast time already and I need some shopping but I'm Bet bound and I don't like other hands touching my shopping.
Might you be able to assist?
Sure What's oh, oh Oh my god Okay No, no, no, that's not that's not yours.
That's not yours What I thought there was bricks in there.
Oh okay all right oh my god wait this is kind of terrifying i tell you what asbestos never gave anybody third degree burns this way yes no why i even bother what is happening i preferred him gold personally i thought we were finished with it thank goodness you're here What's going on?
Wait, so I follow him in there?
Is the mayor ready to see me or?
Okay, not yet.
Bountain broke.
Here's the...
No, I'll do it for you.
In your steed.
Bobby knocking, is it?
Well, how about I give you two of these?
Thank you!
Watch Bobby's party trick.
Uh...
Oh, what happened?
Oh, I meant st- wait.
Never in all my years of service.
Oh my god!
He wasn't even the real statue!
I think I need to go into the hole, but I'm exploring a little bit first.
The statue's alive.
Yeah, just like New York.
Wait!
is it just all where's the arm where's the arm oh whoa whoa whoa what's happening oh you again when am I going to see the back of you you wee melon heed what actually I've got just the job for you yes sir why don't you head down to price shaggers and pick us up some spirit level bubbles hey boys
how does that Void, welcome back.
Thank you.
Away you go.
We're getting some... some what?
Ah!
It happened.
Uh, can I get some, please?
Oh, lovely.
Are you here to give me a hand with the tattoos?
Yeah.
Oh.
I've got it tough, me.
Yeah, hi, we both do we're tatties.
We're tatties Yep, 42 at bed dirt for breakfast Dirt for dinner, and we used to sleep in sacks Exactly and for what best-case scenario.
We're peeled chopped up and drowned in oil
Oh gosh, I'm really slow Where are we going?
Oh my gosh, the view from up here?
Who's Roger?
Oh!
That's what she wanted, right?
Now she's happy?
Oh, I think my chat broke, you guys.
One second.
Hold on.
Oh my gosh, it's been a long time.
time since my chat is broke one second one second one second one second one second one second one second how free i could see you but i can't see you
moo moo
oh why is the music scary again What's happening?
Hey, you're looking much better, Bessie.
And just in time, too.
We better be setting off.
Oh, we don't want to miss our special appointment.
Oh, I hope we find the place, okay?
Apparently, it's opposite our little field.
The house with the blue door.
Okay, the house with the blue door, right?
kid that wanted milk oh hello oh here it is oh i'm too nervous to knock you do it bessie you're nervous too oh dear oh dear we'll be here all day all right a baby's gotta do what a baby's gotta do oh hello oh
so do you come here often this is awfully nice i got it from a car boot sale No, I went and I was...
I said, that's an awfully strange car boot.
And he said, well, it's a hot tub.
What?
I don't want to get in there.
Don't make me.
Thanks for coming.
Ah!
Can you drink this?
Oh, my.
Is that an udder?
It's an udder, right?
Wait, my chat broke again.
Guys, I need you here.
My chat broke again.
Help!
No!
Oh no!
Man.
Milk shy no more!
A few too many too many here lad, come on, you can sleep it off down the station.
What is that?
Wait, why is my chat keep breaking?
This is so strange.
I might have to read you through OBS or something.
Okay, there you guys are.
Okay.
Um...
We need an adult.
Yeah.
Oh no.
.
An incident occurred here.
Got photos?
I know, I think the incident occurred here.
It's just ectoplasm?
Wait, do you got any more sausages for me?
No?
What's going on in this country?
Rid of me that?
Pickle me this.
Hold on to me, brush my mouth to peace.
Oh, wait, no.
The old guy!
The only normal...
person in this...
town.
Where do we even begin?
He's shaking.
He's shaking and...
He'll never live normally again.
He's so anxious.
This poor guy.
Crime!
Still at large!
No, no, God, no.
Oh, don't do this.
We can avoid this.
No, I'm so sorry.
Please.
Expect it.
Accept my smack of shame.
I'm so sorry.
Can I take your ten, Bob?
No?
All right.
Sorry for the trouble.
What are you wearing?
Green dungarees in a flat cap.
You're not going to believe this.
Oh?
Heavens have beat me.
I need to get that fixed.
What just happened?
How did we end up here?
Hmm.
Oh!
What do you guys think?
Is he dead?
They decapitated him!
I don't think it...
Oh!
Oh my god!
Is he okay?
He's twitching.
He's still alive.
It worked!
It worked?
You think so?
He doesn't even get to...
Well, I don't know.
Oh.
Oof.
As an American who went to Vexpo, I can confirm it was exactly like this.
How many things?
How many people did you punch?
How many?
Or can you only do that if you live there?
This is a barbie area.
Slap.
Sorry, my bad.
You're right.
How many people did you slap?
You okay?
Oh, God.
I don't think he's ever getting out.
I can't believe it worked.
I don't need...
Oh my god, it was him!
His meals for worms, an extra bag of soil.
He's doing crimes!
He's still doing crimes.
I said, in areas?
Well, I could try, but it's your wife.
Weigh, weigh.
Oh, la la, what's going on there?
I can't believe he's doing all these crimes.
I can't believe it.
Is this open up now?
No?
I'm smushing.
Lock him up.
Take away the key.
Do you think it was normal milk or?
Aww.
That's right!
Wait, why did we have to go here again for?
I can't remember actually.
This game is making me bomb
Okay, I think he wants us to go to the...
Oh, oh my god!
Meep!
Did the poison...
The rat poison that were.
Alright, I'll tell him.
Wait, oh.
He's here now.
Wait, there's gossiping about me!
Spirit level bubbles, is it?
Yes.
Zoran, look.
We just got a fresh batch in this morning.
They're in the batch.
Yeah, look.
Okay!
You need this!
Good luck!
Come on!
Ah!
Oh!
They're real?
Oh, it was supposed to be a prank.
Ah!
Silly.
Can't prank me!
I'm going.
I'm through the roof.
Oh.
Hello?
What's going on?
I don't know anything that's happening anymore!
Why is he so tiny?
You can't just ask a person about their size.
I'm going up.
We're going- all things are coming up, Mickey!
Oh my gosh.
The view, finally a good view of this town.
Yeah, what's going on?
Such lovely lashes.
It's just a little guy, oh gosh, the sparkle in his eye!
He's never seen anything so beautiful!
Oh my gosh.
The sun is so...
Massive.
Why is Minto so tiny?
So I says to them, I says, yeah, it's an ovencloth.
Ooh.
Where else am I supposed to put it?
In the oven.
Oh, cry.
Oh.
Watches?
Is that real felt?
Coat for sale.
How much?
Can Bob?
Very reasonable.
I just got four fingers.
I still got that cabbage money.
We got!
Look everyone, this young man's caught bootleg Bill.
It's more of a cumbering grass, really.
Oh my gosh, I'm the talk of the town.
I'm the town's little hero.
Yay!
Hooray!
Oh.
Hip, hip.
Three cheers.
Ah!
Now, now, settle down, settle down.
Thanks to this young man's incredible police work, I can safely declare.
Hip, hip.
in this town has been knocked on the head.
Yeah!
Still at large.
Capture a notorious criminal.
I did do that.
Are you okay?
Kiss the cook.
What do I do now?
Almost out with this one, Charlie.
Terrific job, Susan.
You learned that shilling yet.
Minto shouldn't be exhausting her.
last brain cell and such intense ADHD frolic.
What is going on?
Oh, we're still shopping with the hand, right?
Okay, we're in here.
Um, the rats are still at large.
Uh, um.
Where are you?
Oh, no, you're... Is it back here?
Oh, yes, yes!
Steal!
You want some soup?
Ugh, too wet.
Okay.
You want some peens?
It's peens?
No.
Um...
You want some...
Triple with... bit?
Wait.
Ugh.
Oh, here we go.
You want some tinned pie?
Tiny Tom's?
Too dry.
Okay.
You want some lovely boy soup?
Too red.
You want some big boys tin dinner?
You want some wet m- No, this is too wet.
This is too wet.
You want some soup to push?
Okay.
Well, two meta.
Two meta.
You want some lard?
You want some peens?
You want some soup for her?
You want some butter?
You want some breakfast blend?
Oh, what's this?
Gummy's breakfast blend.
And only...
40 years out of date.
We'll take the lot.
The watch.
Where did the hand come from?
Can be his breakfast blend.
Kind of getting hungry.
Oh, good.
I'm going to dinner soon.
This one's immunized.
How much left do I have the game?
Altogether, that's.
That's?
How much?
Ten bob.
Everything is ten bob.
Pretty close to the end now?
Okay, cool.
Thank you, guys.
Oh, my outline is still here.
Cool.
Where was that guy's...
Was it this way?
My ectoplasm...
Oh, come on.
My ectoplasm outline.
Yeah, exactly.
It's just ectoplasm, everybody.
Okay, I think you've had enough of your greed little piglet.
No, it's okay to be greedy, isn't it?
Eat, wait, wait, wait.
Oh wait.
He's just waiting for me!
Oh, okay, come on, yep, come on through, come on through.
There's a public bridal way, Nish.
I'll get you a key cutter.
I'll call Bonnie right now, in fact.
I'm sorry.
I don't want to be this way.
I don't want to be this tiny.
It's hard for me to.
This poor guy.
I feel so bad.
No, Barbara.
Hold the handrail, Barbara.
Mind those banana skins, Barbara.
Watch out.
Barbara.
Sorry, lad.
I was dreaming about my dead wife.
Gosh, TMI, Rob.
Oh, dear.
I got you.
I've got you.
This is a no-snail zone.
Murder, murder.
Oh, there's another one going down the well.
I killed that one.
Or it died, right?
Oh, dear.
Oh no.
I'm killing them, I'm murdering them!
No snails!
No snails allowed!
Did you get away from me?
I did.
You're fine.
Don't worry.
Oh, horrid snail!
Oh wait, I have to go down because they sealed up the exit.
Okay.
Or she's blocking the exit rather.
Ha ha!
Oh!
Wait, can I, uh...
Can I get a little ride back up?
She didn't choose to be so tiny and full of violence.
Oh!
It's your whole wife!
You know what?
Never mind.
A bull supper?
Wait!
We were gonna get food together?
Me and our whole wives?
A little off-peast here, but another thing worms really love.
A rooster's egg.
It's not an easy snack, but by God is a protein worthy.
Huh.
I forgot about this air.
Oh, they're all fried now.
Oh my gosh, the details are so goofy in this game.
Hello!
Oh,
just kidding.
Yeah, sophisticated!
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Okay.
Did you see the eyes?
I did.
They were all looking at me.
Get them all.
Oh wait, I didn't.
Wait, I missed something.
Wait, what did I miss?
Missed the payoff, but he said it was fine.
Huh?
Wait, what, what, what?
Sorry!
I didn't realize!
Alright, if you must know, cocktail sausage and down the snorkel.
Huh?
You ignore him and keep smacking it.
Oh my gosh, wait!
It's an actual... animal!
I forgot about this area.
Honestly.
made me better I didn't you guys are confusing me hello
where's all where's all the stuff why is everybody closed up it's okay guys we keep going why is everybody closed up Minto is too polite he told me to stop
big too big you know me I don't reckon out can be too big so true people used to rip me for my head and all really high school they used to call me pan head call me fat head fat head I've made big my business and I've done all right yeah yeah your own shop best throw an arm in town yeah Florence is doing well too Three jobs.
And she's nearly got a B-Tech.
Oh, what?
That's true.
She's off to uni next year.
Oh.
There you go.
Come on.
Let's get down Pum and have a yard.
The boys would love to see you.
That one wasn't a fish.
It wasn't.
What else could it have been?
Wait.
No, dang it.
I thought that guy was at the exploding food.
is gonna be there.
Why is everything gone?
Oh no, I've just got off the phone with that Karen.
Turns out, she says don't sell all my clothes unbammed with my get-lap last time.
Oops!
Well, sorry, Karen.
Closing hours.
Oh my gosh, wait, we gotta get the last Yu-Gi-Oh!
I'm pushing cardboard boxes in here.
I'm not sure where to go.
How do I... I can't remember how Oh, he's down here.
Wait, I don't have to see this guy again, do I?
Excuse me!
Oh, okay.
He's asleep.
Oh, but he's got a bed for two.
Wait a second.
No, wait.
You're the brick guy.
You're Nick.
Nick with the bricks.
I don't know.
You lived here, too?
Wait, yeah, there they are, right there together.
Wait, that's so cute.
Oh, so sorry.
I'm sorry.
Oh,
thank you.
He's got really bad IBS or something.
The guy can't stop.
The guy can't stop going to the bathroom.
He's got to get that checked out.
Aww.
We're all here.
Thank you.
Oof, you've got some heat on that.
I know.
It's nearly as big as mine.
It is fucking massive.
Oh, okay.
Someone's...
You don't just say it outright.
License to serve minors.
Oh my gosh, no!
Not at the pub.
I don't know what I'll do now.
You'll keep kicking.
You'll kick through life.
Oh.
That's...
Jasper should have left that fire broke.
Bountain broke.
It's broke.
You okay?
Let's go check on this guy.
Not here.
No, no, no.
They're here.
Hello!
I'm home!
How was it?
Oh yeah, the breakfast blend.
Here for you.
Ooh, it's coming.
It's almost there.
Oh, just another second.
One more push.
Just around the corner for you.
Ooh.
Juicy.
Breakfast in bed.
I'm so hungry, though, you guys.
The Baja Blast Pot.
I kind of want to try it because I've never had Baja Blast before.
I should be able to have the pie, right?
Dinner soon.
Yeah, I'm so hungry.
Oh, we're sharing with the whole town.
Oh, your dinner's ready.
Hello?
What if the person upstairs didn't have...
That's me!
What if he didn't have food?
Oh no, it looks as if our cuckoo clock is broken.
Oh dear, oh dear, it's really broke.
Please won't you help us?
Six o'clock.
Get that clock and bash this mole.
We need to knock him down the hole.
Your garden's fine.
Come here instead and help me slice my crusty bread.
oh wait oh i was supposed to i was pressing buttons instead of
i think it's still a little block help us fix our ticky tongue
where have you been lad can't you see there's 40 moles and one of me
sorry could have proper slides move the handle left and right
a key to make the mince for shepherds tea.
Before we all sit down to eat, we'll have to bash on every beat.
Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, now then lad, my garden's full of dirty moulds you need to call.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Turn the crank and make it snappy.
Snappy, okay.
That meaty ground come out with this.
I need to chop up all my fish.
Help me please, I'm in distress.
I just can't see you all this mess.
Forget that truck.
We need you more.
There's so much soap spilled on the floor.
That's it, young man.
You've mocked enough.
Now help me chop my tatties up.
Help me keep the crime at bay.
My dog needs smoking every day.
Make it quick.
Open his round and make his sick.
Hurry up and make him sick.
Give that filth in all of a stick.
Slice the bread and make him thin.
Careful now we are, machine.
Bites it young and bash that bloke.
Won't you give my dog a stroll?
Finney, let's see what I've got.
Push until we both fall off.
You know here what we both said?
Oh my god, how much more!
Watch that mole until it's dead.
Until it's dead?
Cut straight through that lovely grass.
I don't feel super, but needs most.
Ow!
Why should we all be biking too?
Steady on this bed.
I'm destroying the town!
I think I need a little more.
Everybody's dying!
Hang on, why is it me and so?
Oh, Reggie's quite unwell.
Oh, Reggie!
Oh, yeah!
Landers flying down the road!
Yeah!
I'm a fish!
Who taught you to drive all this?
money's on the shore you need to chop some more of course easy now let's keep it civil look at little Reggie I can't stop now I'll come by tea tonight yeah
Wow it's our clock it's really bright but the ball is in our hole bush is it he's nearly dead put the garden to his dead push that box and these too easy to it's good for you bang the deal now please don't fuss it's better if you stay with us time to ticking tiki talk get in match it make him stop you have the right to get knocked out chop up fish your blood comes out i miss my dad i miss my mom look in you out to me hope the smashy buggy sounds don't be coy now stick around build the fish build the hole need to see push the ball push the turtle push the mouse look at me don't fix the glass
We can't do it anymore.
Please.
I'll tell you what, Lovie.
He'll be ready for you now if he'd like to pop in.
Okay, thank you.
Oh, thank goodness you're here.
No!
I'm just about to talk into this delicious amsani.
I have lost the mayoral mustard.
Oh!
Oh, we beat her!
Oh, title drop!
Yay!
Oh my goodness.
Okay, hold on.
I need to eat some chips real quick because I'm actually gonna starve.
Even though I'm about to go to dinner.
Just a chip.
Just a little chip.
I'm an honorary Brit.
I don't think I understood literally anything that was going on in there.
Oh, well, thank you so much for the food.
Just a chip.
Just a wee chip.
Crisps.
Wait, yes, these are crisps.
These are not chips.
These are crisps.
We were so right.
That game was crazy.
That game was insane.
And I, I went insane with it.
I think...
I'm not British enough.
One more crisp for the road.
What a day.
You earned those.
Thank you.
You don't even know the day that I've had.
I held a baby for the first time today.
And then I held two.
And then they were like, no, you have to have three.
It was...
Yeah, poor baby.
Poor baby.
Now, for the first time.
It was scary.
I'm tired.
And now I get my reward.
I get to go out to dinner.
Thank you, everybody, so much for playing.
Thank goodness you're here.
I wish I could talk with you guys more, but I gotta skiddle.
Battle for Phu!
Scared me.
That's my ride, if you can hear him.
Triko, thank you so much for the pig!
Make me tag you!
Thank goodness you're here!
Panic, that's me.
Otomito!
Thank you so much.
Well, thank you so much.
For some reason, it's one of those types of games I can't like, if I close out of the game, you know, I can't read everybody's...
That was so silly.
It was so silly.
It was like a Mr. Bean episode, huh?
Thank you guys so, so much.
Make sure to Britishly declare Blooming Heck.
I love... I miss that guy.
He was my favorite.
Thank God you're here meant to finish the game.
Yeah!
Thank you so much for the tiny kitten.
I gotta go, guys.
I gotta go.
I gotta skidaddle.
Oh, I'm going to go get a cuppa and...
And nod off.
I don't know what...
Not really.
How do you say eat in British?
Out you bring toe.
Cheers, love.
Nom.
consume yeah that's what i'm gonna get that's what i'm gonna do do i can't even think straight i can't even talk straight because i'm so hungry oh so chill yo chill yo eat it outside bye bye thank you so much thank you wait thank you bye-bye wait how do i get through this
on oh let's keep going okay bye